today nate has 100 bananas he will eat
two of them every day
is the number of bananas nate has left
proportional to the number of days that
pass and i encourage you to pause this
video and think about this
and what's interesting here they're not
saying is the number of bananas eaten
they're saying the number of bananas
nate has left proportional to the number
of days that pass
so let's draw a little table here to
think about this a little bit more so
i'm going to make three columns
i'm going to make three
columns
so in the first column this is going to
be the number of days that pass
so days number
of days
that
pass
so that's this right over here the
number of days that pass and this middle
column i'm going to write the number of
bananas nate has left
number
of bananas
bananas
bananas left
and over here i want to make the ratio
between the two in order for this to be
a proportional relationship the ratio
between these two has to be constant so
bananas left
so i'm going to divide the second column
by the first column bananas
left
left divided by
days past
days days
past
all right so let's think about it a
little bit
when is when one day has passed how many
bananas will he have left well that one
day he will have eaten two bananas so
you're going to have 98 bananas left and
so what's the ratio of bananas left to
days past what's 98
over 1 which is going to be equal to 98.
all right
when two days have passed how many
bananas is going to have left well he's
going to consume two more bananas so
he's going to have 96 left and so what's
the ratio it's going to be 96
to 2
which is equal to 40 which is equal to
48. so clearly this ratio is not
constant it changed just from going from
one day to the next day so we don't have
a constant ratio of bananas left to days
past so this is not
this is not a proportional
proportional
proportional relationship now things
might have been a little bit different
if they said the number of bananas nate
has eaten is that proportional to the
number of days that passed well yeah
sure because then if this was if this
was the number of bananas eaten
if this was the number of bananas eaten
then it would always be two times the
number of days that passed so that would
be two and that would be four and then
this then these ratios would always be
two but that's not that's not what they
asked for they they wanted us to compare
a number of bananas left to number of
days that pass